okay there's there's always lots of
complications
uh because we think too much but
we've got the hassan
we're going forward
you don't have to work out what one's
got the most weight on it
right because it's it's pretty obvious
if you're square then you've never
really meant to hit them you're more
interested in your own how do i look you
know
right so so forward now this one is
lighter than this one with weight so you
can turn that one easy so you
look it's easy
but if i was to put them together in a
flowing motion
i'm working on natural ability
this is shifting forward
this releases the strike
that releases that
that releases that now the next problem
i see is you're you're here so now
you've got
a 50-50 or you want to tip it with that
leg and then you
and then you have to push off it again
where if it's a natural flow
that's there that's there that's
and then you've got that repeating again
you see
so you start thinking
oh that's the same as that
and
you get less and less
so then it becomes
yeah
here
so i'm making the front foot become the
back one
and then step forward and then go back
i'm doing the backwards and going
forwards now if i leave that it's got a
twist at the end
i don't care who says it i had um
i had one of my
teachers query on my foot opening i said
i i got bad knees
and i found over the years by leaving
that foot there
it always twists at the end but this is
an actual thing of the body you know
and i think oh i've just done it then
so why would i
why would i
destroy my body
so yeah
the front
the front foot becomes the back foot
okay
so you're going to do the whole thing
now
and you're going to try to find these
pieces you're looking for the pieces
rather than the perfect character